fue el epicentro del comercio de
esclavos y uno de los puertos más
importantes para los españoles durante
la conquista siglos después la joya
turística de colombia cartagena es uno
de los motores económicos y el lugar
seguro para la inversión en un país tan
rico en recursos como desigual héctor
trujillo es miembro de la élite de
antaño y fue gerente regional de la
asociación nacional de empresarios y el
poder empresarial está en manos de
empresas extranjeras esta empresa están
direccionadas tanto en su parte
económica como en su parte política
desde el centro de colombia para él en
plena campaña electoral la política para
los empresarios tradicionalmente de
derecha pasa a un segundo plano si de
dinero se trata pero grandes
conglomerados con tal de quedarse pactan
con crecer
y la clase media la que estar sufriendo
y el empresario intermedio para ser
testigos de esa creciente inversión
basta con visitar las viejas casonas de
la perla del caribe hoy convertidas en
hostales hoteles boutique y lujosos
restaurantes
ya des martínez pasa la mayor parte de
sus días en hesemann y el otrora sector
más pobre de la cartagena amurallada hoy
protagonista del boom turístico en
españa según ella los recursos que van y
vienen no los llegan a beneficiar a
todos la riqueza como tal
no se ve reflejada de 100% la mayoría de
la gente de barrio las mamás se
constituyen porque no consiguen un
empleo porque no hay una capacitación
porque hay veces que tanto quieren
trabajar quieren digamos que salir
adelante para una oportunidad es su
verdadera realidad como la de muchos
otros miles de cartageneros al servicio
de la industria y del turismo está en la
periferia unas 80 mil personas habitan
en este barrio en donde la pobreza y la
abstención electoral van de la mano al
área ya desconfía en que con su voto
contribuir a que la situación algún día
cambie su tía hair opina lo contrario la
gente por aquí casi la mayoría de la
gente no vota
porque los políticos no hacen nada por
este barrio entonces a veces la gente le
da miedo dicen todo está para que no le
quiten las ayudas
según el banco mundial colombia es el
segundo país más desigual de américa
latina después de brasil como bien lo
prueba el diario vivir en 2 cartagenas
reflejo de dos colombias distintas uno
con un desarrollo a todo vapor y otro
que siente que jamás saldrá de la
pobreza